I'm very proud to say we are kicking off
our new series Vlad to Dad where we help
our very own Vlad GTA prepare for
fatherhood for her first story I took
latch shopping to help him and his wife
Marion build a baby registry for their
little girl as a father of four I've had
a lot of practice and I have a few
opinions on what he needs so we went to
okay they got the pictures they got all
of them apparently we went to a Target
in the Bronx and as you'll see not only
did Vlad learn a lot we also had a good
time
today the work begins all right because
it costs hundreds of thousands of
dollars to raise a child from birth to
18. and we're gonna start spending that
money today okay yeah
so at this point you've got four I have
four yeah I've done this I'll let you in
a little secret I don't remember
anything really it's a complete blank
but I'm hoping that when I see
everything again it'll refresh my memory
it'll come back it's like riding a
bicycle
[Music]
all right
oh here we go oh okay lesson number one
when it comes to kid clothes
only have the baby clothes that actually
fit your child in the drawer if you have
stuff in there for three month olds and
six month olds and nine month olds just
because they're cute you will pull them
out in a high pressure moment and you
will have the wrong item all right and
you will drive yourself nuts
bam
hey hey okay we'll talk we'll talk about
all this in a second okay I want to show
you something really cool okay this is
your daughter
this is your daughter's an infant this
is your daughter has a slightly larger
babe okay we're gonna carry your
daughter using some help from a
Contraption that's really useful just
come over all right let's go let's go
[Music]
I'm gonna make sure my head is propped
up yes there you go not bad not bad all
right you know what I'm doing here all
right these are carriers the other thing
I would recommend is a wrap it is
is an ancient
tried and tested way of carrying a baby
around the babies love it
so you go ahead you do what he thinks
best
[Music]
a lot of work it's well but it's a lot
of work fine yeah it is but but now
you can play the guitar oh you can walk
and talk
you can drink and toast you can have a
good old time look at that something's
never changed good old Pampers
you're gonna be good with these for a
little while this is 104 diapers Perfect
10 a day 10 a day it could be 15 could
be 20 a day yeah 20 poops and peas a day
[Music]
so what's the most important thing you
got to remember when you're looking at a
car seat so you got to make sure that
your your car seat is compatible with
your car but also with your stroller
because this is going to be the baby uh
rolls around in for the first three
months at least yeah just shop around
and make sure you you know it's light
it's mobile and you feel comfortable
cleaning it and adjusting it this is
called the uh snot sucker
the snot sucker uh you put the tube in
the baby's nostril and because they
don't know how to blow their nose you
have to suck out of the snot and so you
this what do you do with it you swallow
it it's in your mouth and you sometimes
sometimes it just stays in the tube if
you're lucky if you're lucky flat oh if
you're lucky it stays in the tube damn I
am bam all right time to pay the piper
Tony made me get these jeans just saying
it for the record Marion this is Tony's
baby's first jeans come on these are
great
thank you for coming thank you my
brother
I'll see you see you soon thank you
thank you
[Music]
there's so much stuff I didn't even see
I left some stuff behind Okay thank you
my brother yeah all right thank you
but I thought you were gonna still show
up by carrying the baby my little baby
uh by the way Tony that was so good yeah
that was great
who produced that
was our cameraman Vino million who was
our camera person uh they were great I
gave you good advice I got a three-page
list of advice here I'll post it